In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 7th, on which we commemorate the Holy
martyr, Sazon.
On the 7th of the month, we celebrate the vigil of the Nativity of the Mother of God and
the memory of the Holy martyr, Sazon.
The date Sazon was a native of Lyconia in Asia Minor and lived in the reign of Diocletian
in the years 284 through 305.
He was called Tharassios before baptism and had been a shepherd.
He went on to learn the art of pastoring a spiritual flock and brought a large number
of pagans to the faith by his teaching.
One day, he was shown in a vision that it was time to shed his blood in the confession
of Christ, so he went down to Pompeo Polis in Solisia and entered the Eidel's temple where
they worshipped a golden statue of Diana.
He cut off its right hand and broke it into small pieces that he distributed to the poor.
There arose no small stir among the pagans when they discovered the theft and their confusion
was all the greater when the blessed Sazon, forstalling suspicion, gave himself up.
He was immediately led before Maximian, the governor of Solisia.
When blows failed to weaken his steadfast confession of Christ, he was made to run in iron
sandals covered in nails.
On seeing his blood fall on the ground like a beneficent dew, the saint was filled with
the joy not of this world that remained until he gave up his soul into the hands of God,
so cruelly beaten that his bones and entrails were visible.
When the executioners made a fire to burn his body, a violent storm sprang up.
The rain put out the fire and the pagans ran off in terror so that pious Christians were
able to take up the body of the holy martyr.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.